pourvu que ça dure vous est présenté par
echodds echorganisme qui agit pour une
économie respectueuse de
[Musique]
l'environnement
bonjour bienvenue dans pourvu que ça dur
l'émission qui rend l'éch responsable
sur publ SNA aujourd'hui on part à la
montagne entre fond des glaciers perte
du manteau neigeux le massif porortte
les stigmates les plus visibles du
réchauffement climatique mais au fait
quel est l'impact réel des sports
d'hiver sur l'environnement comment les
stations peuvent-elles se relever et se
réinventer réponse dans quelques
instants face à l'urgence climatique les
bonnes pratiques ne manquent pas
reportage dans deux stations qui mettent
les bouchées doubles pour préserver la
montagne Val mororel et les arcs enfin
Dominique Thot le directeur général de
la Compagnie des Alpes sera notre invité
avec lui nous reviendrons sur les
objectifs ambitieux qu'il s'est fixés
pour réduire l'empreinte carbone de ces
stations à horizon
2030 quel est l'impact réel des
activités de sport d'hiver est-ce que le
ski aggrave ou pas le réchauffement
climatique réponse avec vous Sébastien
Moira bonjour bonjour merci d'être avec
nous vous êtes membre du conseil
d'administration de Mountain Riders une
association qui accompagne les stations
dans leur transformation on va pas y
aller par quatre chemins on a affire
quand même à un tourisme de masse à la
montagne avec chaque hiver des hordes de
de vacanciers qui qui débarquent qui
potentiellement abîme la nature et les
écosystèmes je grossil le trait ou c'est
un peu ça quand même c'est une réalité
en parti après on part tous en
vacances et l'impact qu'il a est réel
quand on multiplie par à peu près 10 les
fréquentations pendant les les les
grosses périodes que ce soit à la
montagne ou même des fois en bord de mer
ben on faut gérer 10 fois plus de volume
d'eau et il y a beaucoup plus d'impact
sur de présence au milieu de la nature
et donc une vie sauvage qui doit être
conciliée avec la vie humaine et donc
tout cet impact ben il faut trouver le
meilleur équilibre pour que ça se passe
bien bon la question évidemment face à
ce tourisme de masse c'est de savoir
quel est l'impact carbone notamment des
sports d'hivers et ça je l'ai appris en
préparant cette émission
euh quand on se skiffe on pollue pas ou
peu la pollution elle vient d'abord du
transport et ensuite de l'hébergement
ouais toute petite nuance là-dedans
c'est qu'en fait les chiffres ils sont à
autour de 3 % sur le domaine skiable
alors 3 % c'est quoi 3 % de l'ensemble
des gaz à effet de serre émis par le
l'activité touristique ouais mais 3 %
par le domaine skillable donc on
pourrait se dire bah finalement c'est 57
% sur les transports c'est donc il y a
beaucoup plus sur d'autres domaines mais
si on vient pas à la montagne alors là
en l'occurrence pour faire des sports
divivers on n pas de transport on
diminue aussi les transports donc
l'impact même des remontées mécanique
sur le Global va pas être énorme mais en
venant à la montagne on a aussi un
impact parce qu'on vient en transport
voilà parce qu'on s'équipe parce qu'on
s'alimente et donc du coup il y a un
impact quand même qui est assez
important mais très peu du fait de skier
en tant que tel très peu que sur le fait
de SK c'est bien évidemment de mesurer
l'impact carbone est-ce qu'il faut aller
plus loin et regarder aussi les dégâts
sur la biodiversité est-ce qu'on a des
chiffres est-ce que le bilan est lourd
ou pas ouais aujourd'hui on parle même
de 6e extinction de masse au niveau de
la biodiversité donc du
coup en lien avec les activités d'hiver
et de ski les activités humaines au sens
large on va même aller au-delà c'est que
le dérèglement climatique va créer en
montagne un effet de monté des niveaux
de la montagne et donc un effet de
montée de la végétation plus ça se
réchauffe plus en fait il va faire chaud
haut donc du coup on perd on
déséquilibre complètement l'écosystème
avec le dérèglement climatique et c'est
particulièrement marqué en territoire de
montagne qu'est-ce qui est le plus
problématique aujourd'hui c'est c'est la
fondte des glaciers ce sont les les
précipitations qui tombent qui tombent
de plus en plus souvent le SA sous forme
de pluie et de moins en moins de neige
ou c'est la fonte plus rapide du manteau
du manteau neigeux c'està dire que si on
regarde sur un prisme sport d'hiver bah
le fait de d'avoir moins de neige ou des
précipitations moins régulières parce
que voilà cette année on est quand même
pour le moment assez gâté euh ça fait
qu'on peut plus prédire les choses de la
même manière on est plus sûr d'avoir de
la neige à 1500 m et donc du coup les
activités sont impacté et donc du coup
bah c'est tout le prixme la fonte des
glaciers c'est une conséquence les
conséquences sont énormes et les impacts
sont diverses mais si on prolonge le
trait euh à quoi on s'attend dans les
prochaines décennies même si c'est loin
euh le moindre enigement est garanti non
non non aujourd'hui euh on a un risque
vraiment toutes les stations en dessous
de 1500 m d'altitude elles sont vraiment
en péril euh on a la moitié des stations
qui sont quand même concernées au moins
au niveau des départs des stations
actuelles euh au niveau de 1500 m et
donc du coup euh toutes ces stations-là
vont devoir se réinventer dans les
années à venir hmm comment on fait pour
sauver justement bah les euh la montagne
les sports d'hivers ces stations qui
sont en basse en basse en basse montagne
en dessous de de 2500 m d'altitude euh
il y en a beaucoup qui multiplient les
les euh les initiatives et bon je
rappelle chez Mountain rider euh vous
délivrez des des labels ce sont les les
flocons c'est ça les flocons ver voilà
c'est ça euh euh aux stations qui sont
les plus vertueuses euh on s'inspire de
qui qui sont les bons élèves aujourd'hui
alors pour revir un tout petit peu sur
flan convers c'est une démarche
d'amélioration continue des des
territoires de montagne on a pour
marquer cette évolution trois niveaux de
labellisation un flocon deux flocons
trois flocons aujourd'hui on a aucune
station qui sont labéisé trois flocons
euh et on a une vraie progression quand
même de toutes les stations un flocon de
flocons on a l'anemb ver cor sur de
flocons on a d'autres stations c'est
vous avez pouvez toutes les retrouver
sur le site internet ces engagements
l'idée c'est de mettre en avant des
initiatives donc il y en a qui vont
faire des choses sur l'énergie il y en a
qui vont faire des des choses sur la
gestion de l'eau il y en a qui vont
faire des choses sur la biodiversité et
c'est évoluer sur tous ces domaines pour
être le plus vertueux et s'adapter
effectivement à ce dérèglement
climatique on a une idée du nombre de de
de stations aujourd'hui qui ont déjà
arrêté complètement le ski euh même si
on a déjà parlé de celles qui sont
amenées à devoir arrêter parce que sous
1500 m
d'altitude pour l'instant le chiffre
exact il est il est pas là après on a
des des stations qui vont aller qui ont
déjà fixé du coup à l'horizon 2030 le
fait d'arrêter complèt le ski comme
notamment metabier qui est dans le Jura
mabier elle a pris les devants donc pour
lancer une transition j'enis dire en
douceur et pour ne pas subir les
événements on devrait s'en inspirer
d'autres devraient s'en inspirer et en
faisant quoi d'ailleurs aussi ouais ah
c'est un peu ce que je disais tout à
l'heure quand on parlait des flocons
c'est alors c'est un exemple
effectivement là c'est radical on va
arrêter l'activité de ski on va se
diversifier on va aller sur de la
randonnée on va aller sur voilà vraiment
le fait de s'immerger dans la nature
d'aller à la montagne parce que c'est
beau parce que c'est des écosystèmes qui
sont diversifiés qui nous attire qui
nous détendent qui nous repose je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on a quand même bien
besoin en été ou en été mais même en
hiver parce que en hiver on peut très
bien se dire bah on part du coup là où
avant il y a de la neige on part bah
c'est encore vert et puis on va marcher
2 heures bien équipé et puis finalement
on arrive les pieds dans la neige alors
c'est pas assez dense pour se dire qu'on
va aller faire du ski et qu'on va
chausser les skis par contre on peut
mettre les chaussures adéquates et
justement diversifier aussi laproche de
la montagne que ce soit en hiver ou que
ce soit au printemps ou en été allez
Merci à VOUS Sébastien Moir donc je
rappelle ê membre du conseil
d'administration de Mountain Riders
merci merci à vous alors on vient de le
voir face à l'urgence climatique les
bonnes pratiques ne manquent pas
reportage dans deux stations qui mettent
les bouchées doubl pour sauver et
préserver la montagne manuel
aigre l'industrie du sport d'hiver c'est
11 milliards d'euros mais face à
l'urgence climatique les stations de ski
pourraient disparaître dans les
prochaines années en 2022 50 % d'entre
elles ont fermé une semaine à Noël en
raison du manque de neige et ce n'est
que le début 110 stations sur 270 sont
aujourd'hui menacées alors comment
sauver le sport d'hiver et ses 120000
emplois peut-on réellement verdir cette
industrie et réinventer le tourisme de
montagne face à cette tendance les
gestionnaires de domaines skiaable
réagissent et se tournent naturellement
vers le poste qui fait tâche dans le
bilan carbone celui des dameuses à lui
seul il représenterait entre 70 et 90 %
des gaz à effet de serre d'une station
de ski et en moyenne une nuit vous
arrivez à faire quoi 60 70 % du domaine
depuis 1 an en sa voix le domaine des
Arcs tente de bannir le diesel de ses
dameuses au profit d'un carburant bien
plus propre sans avoir à modifier les
moteurs aujourd'hui on a 29 dammeuses et
toutes sont alimentées par de l'hvo
qu'un carburant issu de d'huile végétale
de déchets alimentaires et autres rec et
l'énorme avantage de ce carburant c'est
qu'il permet selon laadme de réduire de
83 % les émissions de CO2 soit une
économie pour la planète de 2000 tonnes
de CO2 par an mais ce carburant propre
est 26 centimes plus cher au litre que
le diesel agricole un surcoup de 200000
€ chaque année qui ne décourage pas pour
autant la station qui souhaite aller
encore plus loin pour agir efficacement
il n'y a pas 50 solutions les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre sont
majoritairement du au placement des
touristes vers la montagne alors pour
les encourager à laisser leur voiture au
garage la station des Arcs abat sa
dernière carte
elle met à disposition un funiculaire
électrique tout juste rénové qui relie
la gare TGV la plus proche au domaine
skiable on peut prendre un TGV
directement depuis Paris Londres et
Bruxelles et arriver directement à Bour
Saint-Maurice vous marchez 5 minutes
vous prenez le funiculaire en 7 minutes
vous êtes aux AR donc c'est un confort
incroyable que aujourd'hui on a à peu
près 20 22 % de nos clients qui
l'utilisent et on se fixe l'objectif à
plus long terme d'avoir 30 % de nos
visiteurs à horizon 2030 qui utilisent
le funiculaire là encore 630000 tonnes
de CO2 économisé chaque année mais y
a-t-il des solutions pour aller encore
plus loin sachant qu'en France 80 % de
la production électrique n'est pas
totalement
verte les domaines skiables sont
gourmands en énergie électrique pour
faire tourner plein régime les 3350
remontées mécaniques il faudrait 670 MW
soit les 2/ers de la production d'un
réacteur nucléaire en sa voix une
station de ski a décidé de mener la
guerre à la surconsommation électrique
il s'agit de Valmorel on en a passé du
tempsin pendant 3 ans on a développé son
pendant 3 ansin c'est David qui est en
charge de relever le défi à la base il
développe des systèmes de surveillance
vidéo équipé d'intelligence artificielle
capable de contrôler la sécurité des
usagers à bord des remontées mécaniques
il y a une nécessité à vérifier que les
passagers sont bien embarqués sur le
télésiège ce qui est un moment assez
particulier hein puisque contrairement à
un avion on décolle avant d'attacher sa
ceinture de sécurité qui est le
garde-cor pour cela on met un œil à la
remontée mécanique cela permet de faire
un traitement d'image ce qui est la base
de not technologie dite intelligence
artifici ci mais alors comment détourner
de son usage premier cet outil ultra
intelligent pour réaliser des économies
sur la facture d'électricité notre
objectif à nous c'est de de gagner 20 %
de l'énergie électrique ce qui
correspond à un passage de la vitesse de
5 m second à 4 m second 20 % de la
vitesse économisée 20 % de l'énergie
pour le skieur c'est quasiment
insensible David souhaiterait confier en
partie les commandes de la remontée
mécanique à son ordinateur qui
ajusterait en temps réel la vitesse en
fonction de la fréquentation l'optimum
du système serait d'avoir un pilotage
automatique par par l'intelligence
artificielle pour lire comme ça lorsque
les caméras détectent la foule
l'ordinateur ne change rien en revanche
il ralentit la cadence à chaque moment
de répis d'après ces calculs ces
variations de vitesse permettraient
d'économiser en moyenne 15000 € par
remontée mécanique soit 10 millions
d'euros par saison uniquement pour la
région auverg ronalpe mais ça c'est pour
les stations qui ont encore de la neige
celles dont les remontées sont désormais
fermées sont de plus en plus nombreuses
à s'engager dans l'œufre qu saisons et
la diversification des activités comme
la randonnée ou le VTT une des pistes
aujourd'hui pour sauver l'activité et
maintenir les
[Musique]
emplois allez on continue à parler de
ces stations qui investissent pour
préserver la montagne dominiqueo bonjour
bonjour David JAC merci là directeur
général de la Compagnie des Alpes faut
rappeler vous exploitez une dizaine de
stations de de hautes montagnes dans les
Alpes essentiellement la Plagne les arcs
tiges valdiser cerchevalier les menus
rgion oublie vous y gérez l'ensemble des
remontées mécaniques et parfois aussi la
gestion des pistes qui comprend
notamment les dameuses et pas seulement
c'est un peu rapide hein mais c'est ça
l'idée c'est ça et éventuellement la
production de neige de culture également
sur le sujet qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui la montagne durable est-ce
qu'on peut dire que tous les acteurs du
secteur aujourd'hui sont pleinement
investis pleinement mobilisé il y a cet
objectif d'atteindre cette neutralité
carbone en 2037
oui alors pour ce qui nous concerne nous
on est des acteurs au sens large de vous
les acteur ouais les acteurs au sens
large les acteurs sont tous conscients
du sujet le réchauffement climatique
c'est pas une opinion c'est pas une
idéologiste un fait scientifique et tout
le monde l'a vu et donc tout le monde
tous les acteurs se mettent en se mettre
en marche chacun à son rythme avec ses
moyens pour pouvoir s'adapter et et
limiter l'impact bon 2037 donc pour
l'ensemble du du secteur pour la
neutralité carbone le problème c'est que
l'essentiel du bilan carbone en montagne
est constitué par ce qu'on appelle
pardon c'est un peu technique les
émissions indirectes le fameux scope 3
notamment les émissions liées au
transport des vacanciers au logement des
vacanciers or or or ce scope 3 n'est pas
inclus dans cet objectif de neutralité
carbone je trouve ça ennuyeux alors
d'abord c'est pas parce que l'essentiel
c'est le scope 3 qu'il faut pas attaquer
à la misère qu'on produit nous-même sur
le scope 1 et 2 et c'est ça l'objectif
qu'on s'est donné d'être net zéro
carbone sans crédit carbone sans achat
de de compensation sans indulgence comme
on disait au Moyen-Âge on achetait des
indulgences c'est de la vraie réduction
de la réduction durable et pérenne
ensuite il y a le scope 3 le scope 3
c'est ce qui est moins c'est la
résultante du choix des clients oui du
choix des clients plus ou moins qu'
s'entend ou j'allais dire puisque il
manque de mobilité décarboné et
notamment de service ferroviaires donc
un certain nombre d'entre eux sont
condamnés entre guillemets à prendre
leur voitures leurs voitures qui
elles-mêmes sont sur une trajectoire de
de décarbonation mais c'est pas encore
le cas aujourd'hui et c'est pour ça que
nous c'est un choix qui est fait par les
clients que nous que que nous
accompagnons sur ces sujet là et et nous
souhaitons participer à la décarbonation
de la destination
on a pris un certain nombre
d'initiatives on avait rétabli le train
avec le Travelski Express entre Londres
et Bours sa Maurice et là on était
absolument sûr que c'était des clients
qui basculaient de l'avion vers le train
un mode qui est moins carboné qui n'est
pas décarboné mais qui est moins carboné
que l'avion mais alors comment comment
faire plus comment inciter encore plus
les skieurs à prendre le train à
délaisser la voiture on peut pas les
forcer hein non on veut pas les forcer
mais on veut leur produire une offre
disponible et c'est ça tout l'enjeu
c'est ça qui a présidé au fait qu'on ait
rétabli ce service ferroviaire qu'on a
eu également augmenter le le service
ferroviaire l'année dernière sur Paris
aujourd'hui ce n'est plus le cas on
s'investit sur ce sujet-là on a fait un
appel d'offre européen pour trouver des
opérateurs qui seraient prêts à venir
jusqu'à Bour saint-morrice soit de
Londres soit de Paris soit d'Amsterdam
via Bruxelles et donc c'est ça notre
responsabilité euh moi je ne suis pas un
opérateur ferroviaire en revanche on
doit on peut créer les conditions on
doit on se doit de créer les conditions
pour qu'il y ait plus de service et de
mobilité décarboné l'objectif de la
Compagnie des Alpes il est plus
ambitieux que celui du secteur c'est le
net zéro carbone horizon 2030 et pas
2037 comment vous faites pour aller plus
vite que les petits copains que le
secteur on va plus vite parce que nous
avons la capacité d'investir ouais et
donc cette transition écologique les
stations on a dit 2030 elles le seront
peut-être un peu avant on a la faculté
d'investir d'investir sur nos bâtiments
d'investir sur les consommations
d'investir d'arrêter les énergies
fossiles comme on l'a fait depuis
l'année dernière déjà totalement et donc
tout ça a un impact sur notre scope 1 et
2 euh et pas le 3 non plus mais pas
encore le 3 le 3 c'est à la fois les
clients et à la fois les fournisseurs et
c'est quel pourcentage du des émissions
totales de CO2 le scope 3 ah pour pour
nous on va le faire le décompte exact
cette année mais on est de l'ordre de 80
%. ah ouais donc on on néglige entre
guillemets 80 % des émissions de CO2 on
néglige on n pas le j'ai pas le contrôle
j'ai pas la main mais je peux faire des
choses il faut faire des choses et donc
mes fournisseurs on essaie de ne plus
avoir de fournisseurs trop lointains
ouais on essaie de rapatrier
l'impact sur notre territoire le
bénéfice de l'impact sur notre
territoire vous êtes en ligne ou ou en
avance ou en retard par rapport à à vos
objectifs 2030 c'est bien se projeter
mais on est un peu en avance à l'heure
où on se parle on est un petit peu en
avance on avait sous-estimé
la réduction des émissions carbon lié au
h donc ce carburant qui est issu des
huiles de friture que nous récupérons de
nos parcs que nous traitons et qui sert
de carburant sur au Dameus dans les bus
dans les bus que nous exploitons àtig
valiser et dans les chaudières de nos
ateliers et pour la première fois cette
année Résidence MMV au
Corbier dans les hébergements on l'a vu
dans le reportage les dameuses polluent
énormément donc chez vous ça fonctionne
avec de l'huile de friture ça veut pas
dire que les dameuses aujourd'hui et les
bus n'émettent plus de CO2 du tout non
le H par rapport au diesel divise par 10
les émissions c'est déjà ça il reste 10
% pour ces 10 % là nous travaillons à
créer une usine en France de fabrication
de dameuse 100 % électrique nous avons
investi beaucoup avec un un opérateur
français 100 %
électrique la première dameuse est déjà
en test à tigne et la première présérie
nous avons commandé huit pré-séries la
première pré-série sera livrée à
sererchevalier dans euh au courant de la
saison donc ça a monté en puissance
absolument on ne lâche rien à quel
horizon toutes les dameuses seront 100 %
électriques ah une dameuse à 7 8 ans
donc on peut considérer qu'à 7 8 ans on
aura gagné les 10 derniers pour voilà et
c'est ça l'enjeu si tout ceci à la fin
de la saison pas celle-ci mais la
prochaine euh s'avère satisfaisant en
terme de d'exploitation et aujourd'hui
ça l'est en déjà en terme de autonomie à
ce moment-là on veillera à créer une
industrie française un pôle de
production en France pour les dameux 100
% électrique qui sont la prochaine
génération Dom on oublie ou pas des des
leviers il faut des moyens vous l'avez
dit quels sont les on aborder tous les
leviers pour réduire votre empreinte
carbone oou il y en a d'autres ah il y
en a une multitude d'autres que nous
actionnons évidemment classiquement
l'isolation des bâtiments un meilleur
usage un meilleur usage de de de la
chaleur première ch chose la deuxè on a
aussi des idées sur des la tête des
canons à neige comme on appelle où nous
nous comment s'appelle nous avons
développé notre propre technologie qui
réduit de 15 % l'usage de l'énergie et
de l'eau ça pose des questions pardon ce
recours à la neige artificielle parce
que prélever la ressource en eau alors
qu'on manque de neige on dit que
c'est-êre un petit peu un non sens c'est
que ça grave le problème vous comprenez
le point de vue non là je vais parler
pour la science puisque l'étude vient de
sortir il y a quelques semain ouais sur
un des deux bassins versants de la
Plagne l'eau du bassin versant à 1,4 %
est utilisé pour l'eau potable 1,4 %
pour la neige de culture et 90 % par la
Méditerranée en 3 jours donc après se
pose la question de quand est réalisé le
prélèvement le prélèvement pour nous est
réalisé non pas à la fonte trop de limon
mais réalisé dans les pluies de
septembre octobre au moment où on avale
personne a besoin euh les agriculteurs
les cultures fruitières notamment en
aval des Alpes enant l'v la Méditerranée
n'ont plus besoin d'eau ou moins besoin
d'eau en octobre et novembre et donc il
n'y a pas de conflit d'usage d'eau
parallèlement rappelons que 1,4 % cette
neige de culture est rendue à 90 % dans
le même bassin versant ah oui c'est pas
faux ça ah oui oui non mais ça ça paraît
un
peuycl oui quand vous fabriquez des
pommes 80 % est évaporé sort du bassin
versant
c'est des choses très concrètes
scientifiques et le dernier point on
entend parfois dire la neige de culture
va remplacer la neige naturelle la neige
de culture se produit entre - 3 et 15
degr donc en fait la première qui sera
disparaît qui va disparaître ça sera la
neige de culture dans le cadre d'un
réchauffement climatique ou donc en fait
il faut il faut attendre que la science
s'exprime et quand la science s'exprime
et c'est tranché à ce moment-là tout le
monde est plus rel et on travaille sur
le sujet suivant et ainsi de suite allez
Merci à VOUS Dominique Thot donc
directeur général de la Compagnie des
Alpes merci à vous merci beaucoup on va
maintenant s'intéresser à nos skis qui
terminine quasiment tout le temps et oui
à la
poubelle et oui comment leur donner une
seconde vie la start-up ADN ski basée à
a mis au point des skis 100 %
recyclaable bonjour Émilie bonjour David
bon c'est vrai que c'est un sacré coup
de pouce pour la planète parce que
jusqu'à présent nos skis il termine dans
la nature et ça fondatrice une savoyard
de pur sououche c'est de quoi elle parle
puisqu'elle est née avec des skis au
pied alors pour elle tout part d'un
constat adessé par l'École des Arts et
Métiers de Chambéry chaque année en
France
263000 paires de ski terminent à la
poubelle équivalent de 1500 tonnes des
skis qui après broyage sont parfois
infouit mais souvent incinérés euh donc
avec à la clé des tonnes d'émissions de
CO2 des chiffres qui d'ailleurs sont
sans doute sous-estimés car l'étude date
un peu alors que la pratique elle
ensinene ass cesser d'attirer des
nouveaux adeptes bon on est en 2024 on
ne sait pas aujourd'hui recycler nos
skis alors ce qui pose problème ce ne
sont pas les matières premières David
parce que les matières premières on sait
potentiellement quasiment toutes les
recyclé le souci c'est qu'elles sont
agglomérées les unes aux autres avec une
résine un petit peu comme un sandwich du
coup bah quand le ski arrive en fin de
vie impossible de le décoller bon si on
ne peut pas démanteler nos skis si je
comprends bien c'est à cause de cette
résine exactement c'est cette résine
thermodurcissable qui pose problème et
qui équipe tous les skis aujourd'hui et
justement la start-up a eu l'idé de la
remplacer par une résine thermoplastique
appelée résine thermoset alors cette
résine elle lie également les éléments
entre eux mais la différence c'est
qu'elle peut se dissoudre au contact
d'un liquide qui s'apparente à du
vinaigre résultat et bien les matériaux
peuvent se décoller et potentiellement
être recyclé bah justement de quoi est
composé un ski alors je l'ai appris en
préparant cette émission un ski est
composé de plusieurs sous-couches
toujours on a toujours en tête cette
image de sandwich comme un espèce de
grand club sandwich alors vous avez
d'abord la semelle qui est en
polyéthylène et qui va être mélangé à du
carbone pour une meilleure glisse vous
avez également tout un tas de fibres ça
peut être des fibres de carbone des
fibres de vert des fibres de laine ou
encore des fibres de lin on trouve
également un noyau qui peut-être en bois
ou en mousse sur le dessus vous avez ce
qu'on appelle une top sheet c'est une
feuille plastique très fine qui va
permettre d'accueillir le logo ou le
dessin et puis sur les arrêtes sur les
fameux cars du ski et bien là vous avez
un champ en ABS qui va empêcher
l'humidité de rentrer dans votre ski bon
et parmi ces matériaux certains euh sont
cycl d'autre part ADN a prévu bien de
nintégrer que des matériaux qui sont
recyclables exactement c'est ça l'idée
du coup pour la semelle par exemple et
bien elle a décidé de conserver le
polyéthylène mais sans l'associer à du
carbone parce que le carbone est très
polluant et très difficile à recycler
idem pour la fibre de carbone elle l'
remplacé par une fibre de verre pour le
plastique elle a utilisé un plastique
recyclé et biosourcé les car en acier
eux se recycent à l'infini alors je vais
pas vous citer tous les éléments ce qui
est sûr c'est que le résultat ça vous
donne un ski 100 % recyclable le premier
du marché bon est-ce que ces skis
recyclés sont aussi performants question
importante pour les amateurs de Gliss
bah que des des skis qui sont classiques
alors ils ont été testé institu sur les
pistes par des skieurs amateurs par des
professionnels à guérri et même par des
moniteurs le résultat c'est que la
performance est jugée équivalente mais
avec un petit quelque chose de différent
alors c'est ça qui est étonnant car ces
skis recyclés ont été fondus dans les
mêmes moule que des skis classiques
alors par exemple le ski recyclé il sera
un petit peu plus dur un petit peu plus
résistant voir un petit peu plus souple
un petit peu plus doux en fonction
évidemment de de la gamme que vous aurez
utilisé bon vous parlez des des moules C
ski sont moulé dans les mêmes skis que
les skis Salomon exactement ADN ski a
signé en fait un partenariat avec la
célèbre Marx qui lui a permis de lancer
la commercialisation en échange Salomon
évidemment soigne son image un petit peu
plus Green et puis profite également des
recherches d'ADN ski autour de cette
nouvelle technologie ils sont déjà
commercialisés ou pas c'est SK puis côté
prix est-ce qu'on s'y retrouve alors ils
sont commercialisés de depuis un an sur
le site d'ADN ski et côté prix c'est à
peu près similaire à des prix classiques
il faut compter entre 580 et 630 € la
paire il sera ils seront également mis à
la location à priori l'an prochain dans
certains magasins Skiset hein l'idée
c'est de tester leur durabilité pour
voir s'ils sont aussi résistant que des
skis classiques à l'é preuve donc d'une
location un petit peu intensive bon la
suite de l'aventure pour ADN ski c'est
d'ouvrir ce procédé à la concurrence
pour aider tout le secteur à se verdir
exactement parce que finalement son
ambition c'est pas de lancer une marque
de ski mais bien de créer une nouvelle
technologie pour la faire bénéficier à
tout un secteur un petit peu comme sur
le modèle vous savez de de gorex à
l'époque en attendant Salomon son
partenaire a prévu de lancer ses
premiers skis recyclés recyclabl à
l'hiver prochain avant une possible
ouverture à tout le marché à l'hiver
2026- 2027 y compris aux planches de
glisse donc vous voyez l'aventure ADN
ski ne fait que commencer voilà une
glisse verte c'est possible mercimilie
voilà c'est la fin de pourvu que ça dure
l'émission qui rend l'éco responsable
émission à voir ou revoir sur public
scena il y a du replay bien sûr sur
publicsena.fr rendez-vous dans 2
[Musique]
semaines pourvu que ça dure vous a été
présenté par echodds écoorganisme qui
agit pour une économie respectueuse de
l'environnement